ah
my goodness good morning John so I've
noticed that for the last few videos you
are basically doing just whatever I am
doing I did low budget Bo Burnham you
did a low budget Bo Burnham I did a
Google autofill thing you did a Google
autofill thing I think this is cheating
or at least lazy and so I am going to
make it hard for you by taking you
behind the scenes to one of the most
advanced aquarium exhibits in the whole
world I actually got to tour this
exhibit before it actually existed to
see the complexity of what makes it all
come together because you'd think okay
an aquarium on the coast that can't be
that complicated pump seawater in put
fish in the sea water and it's beautiful
well it is more complicated than that
than three years ago I actually made a
whole video about it and you can watch
it but not all ocean is the same in
particular it's very different at
different depths and there are animals
in the deep sea that basically no one
gets to see it's extremely hard to go
down there it's also hard to get the
animals to the surface and once they're
at the surface the sea water is so
different from the water of the deep sea
that they cannot survive in it but at
the mount Monterey Bay Aquarium they
wanted people to be able to walk amongst
the animals of the deep sea just to
exist in the same space system and if
you go to that exhibit which I have not
been able to do yet you can do just that
you are in the dark walking through
Halls surrounded by animals that
typically inhabit the most difficult to
visit place on Earth and it is designed
to appear to the people walking through
the exhibit that that's all fairly
effortless it's just something for you
to enjoy not for you to understand the
engineering behind how it is possible
but before the exhibit opened I got to
see how that seemingly effortless
cohabitation between humans and deep sea
animals is actually extremely
complicated and fairly precarious so
look when I walked into this I thought
the hardest part of this process was
going to be pressurizing the water to
the same pressures as the deep sea
because water is very heavy and down at
the bottom of the ocean there is a lot
of water on top of you enough pressure
to very easily kill you but I you know I
need to exist at a certain pressure of
atmospheric pressure in order to exist
and the difference between the ocean
pressure at the bottom of the sea and
the ocean pressure at the top of the sea
is bigger than the difference between
air pressure at sea level and space but
many deep sea creatures don't have very
much gas inside of them so if you bring
them up slowly enough they'll be fine so
if you don't actually have to pressurize
the water what's the concern the trouble
is that the sea water itself is
different it has higher salinity very
consistent low temperature and really
consistent gas concentrations that are
very different from surface level water
and so behind every wall at into the
deep there are systems that take water
from Monterey Bay and turn it into a
simulation of deep sea water and it
turns out the hardest part of this is
removing the perfect amount of oxygen
oxygen is great but it is also a super
reactive molecule and these animals are
used to an environment with a super low
oxygen concentration the oxygen of
surface sea level would absolutely kill
many of them and so all of the water in
this aquarium must be run through a
equipment that was designed I'm not
kidding for Semiconductor and
pharmaceutical manufacturing among other
things situations where they really need
to control the amount of different
chemicals present in a system by running
the water over tons of tiny thin
membrane straws with very low pressure
inside the oxygen basically gets sucked
out of the water flowing into the area
of lower oxygen but of course they can't
take out too much or the animals will
asphyxiate it has to be perfectly
balanced every hour of every day I
cannot go to the deep sea and I probably
shouldn't I should leave that to the
researchers who are dedicated to
understanding and protecting it but the
people at the Monterey Bay Aquarium and
places like them have worked extremely
hard to bring those environments those
other worlds within our own to as many
of us as they can to inspire wonder and
joy and awe at the marvels of our planet
and the Curiosity and Ingenuity of the
people who inhabit it John I'll see you
on Tuesday